well senator sanders thank you so much
for joining me i really appreciate it
first i want to say today is the last
day of early voting here in nevada
election day is right around the corner
what's your message to nevadan
specifically about getting out to vote
in this election
uh my message is that this is the most
important election not only in our
lifetimes
but in the modern history of the united
states and if you have not voted yet
please come out to vote there is no
question in nevada is going to be a very
tight election
one of the candidates is going to win by
a relatively small number of votes
and you want to make sure that your vote
counts and i happen to believe
obviously that donald trump is the most
dangerous president in the modern
history of this country
that we cannot tolerate four more years
of a president who lies
all of the time a president who does not
believe
in science who is telling us literally
today
how we're going getting around the
corner on this covert 19
when yesterday we had more cases than
any time since the pandemic began
we need a president who believes in
science and it was going to give us
national guidelines to effectively
combat
uh and defeat this terrible pandemic
because we're not going to get the
economy moving
the way it should not in nevada not las
vegas reno anyplace else
unless we got a handle on the pandemic
and you know that's you know a big a big
issue for a lot of people especially
here like you mentioned the economy
uh are you confident that you know biden
has a plan to to bring those
those jobs back and help those folks who
are on unemployment i think a lot of
people are
concerned that regardless of who's in
the white house they'll still kind of be
left in the in the dark
well let me just say a couple of things
we will not get
the economy back to where it must be and
i know that's especially true
for nevada where you're so much a
hospitality state a tourist state
uh unless people feel comfortable that
when they go
shopping and they go to a casino
whatever they're not going to get sick
so we need to get a handle on covert 19
and obviously
trump has not done that i mean literally
probably today he's holding rallies
where people are going to be in close
proximity to each other they're not
wearing masks they're actually spreading
the virus
that is not what you want from a
president of the united states but above
and beyond
covert 19 i think if you look at what
biden is talking about
number one uh literally on the
first day of a new congress
if the democrats gain control over the
senate we're going to go
forward on an emergency and very strong
covert 19 uh relief package
to protect the unemployed workers of
this country
who today are struggling to put food on
the table
to get health care to literally pay
their rent and not get evicted
that is priority number one and i know
unemployment is much much too high
in nevada today number two under a joe
biden administration we're going to
raise that minimum wage
to 15 bucks an hour we're going to have
equal pay for equal work
so that latino women and and
african-american women are not making
you know 60 cents on the dollar compared
to men uh
we are going to have paid family and
medical leave
we are going to have universal child
care so i think if you
look at the economic agenda of biden it
is a destroy it is a strong agenda
which will protect working families in
nevada and around the country
uh you you won the nevada caucus way
back in february um you're now obviously
supporting joe biden
when it comes to you know if he wins the
election how will you work with him to
ensure that some of
your progressive ideals actually make it
into his administration his white house
well you know i i think as nevada
indicated
uh but not just nevada we won iowa we're
in new hampshire we won a number of
other states
the progressive movement now has tens of
millions of people who are a very
important part of the democratic
coalition and these are people
who want to see a government that
represents
all of us working people the middle
class the poor
minorities and not just the one percent
wealthy campaign contributors and i
think that biden
understands that the progressive
community has to be
an integral part of his administration
that's what i
believe he understands and that's what i
hope and expect
will in fact happen you know one
progressive idea is the green new deal
and you know your position on climate
change biden has said that he's using
the green new deal as a framework but
doesn't fully
you know support the whole plan and
there's also been some back and forth
you know biden and senator harris about
their stance on fracking is any of that
concerning at all to you
look we have differences of opinion we
have differences of opinion
on the green new deal you're right
differences of opinion on health care i
happen to believe in a medicare for all
single-payer system which guarantees
healthcare to all people
as a human right joe's approach to
universal healthcare is a different one
but he would greatly expand the number
of people who have health care
and also lower the cost of prescription
drugs in america so we don't pay
10 times more in some cases for a drug
than they do in canada or mexico
um in terms of the green new deal joe
is not supportive of that but what he is
proposing
is a 2 trillion dollar
investment to transform our energy
system away from fossil fuel and that is
far and away the most aggressive
uh proposal ever brought forth by a
presidential candidate so it's not
my view doesn't go as far as i would
like but it is
very significant and in fact would
create millions of good-paying jobs
as we move to sustainable energy like
solar
which by the way in nevada can be of
huge consequence
uh you can help lead this country and
create many many jobs
by moving aggressively toward solar
and also in terms of energy efficiency
and transportation agriculture
we can undergo a make real real progress
in leading the world in combating what i
believe
is an existential threat to our planet
and that is climate change
and as i mentioned the election just
around the corner we're already seeing
you know pretty high voter turnout when
it comes to the mail ballots and then
uh in-person early voting seeing the
numbers here across the country are you
is that a good sign to you are you are
you looking forward to what what will
happen
you know after tuesday well i'll
give you a better answer to that on
wednesday but uh
i i think in general it's it's a good
sign
uh one of the things that has concerned
me about my republican colleagues and
and trump
is their desire to suppress the vote to
make it harder
for people to participate in the
political process make it harder
for votes to be counted actually um
and i am impressed that all across this
country
uh what we are seeing is voter turnout
at a very very high level and that
that's
uh people who are coming out in person
doing
mail-in ballots we will see what happens
actually on election day
but as of now it looks like it is quite
possible
uh that this will be the highest voter
turnout
as a percentage of our population since
the early 1900s and that is i think a
very good thing
and the gop the trump team is continuing
to you know cast doubt about the
the mail-in ballot system uh just your
thoughts on that i know we've talked to
some other people about
you know their confidence in the process
what about you
but this is what i meant when i talk
about trump
trying to suppress the vote uh
if you talk to leading
republican experts on
voting and elections people like
benjamin ginsburg
who was uh george w bush's key guy in
2000 in florida
knows something about elections but he
will tell you is that voter fraud
in america despite what donald trump
says every day
is very very rare and it you know takes
place from democrats and republicans but
it is very very rare
and what trump is trying to say is that
if he loses the election
which he might very well that it's all
fraud
that you can't trust the election
results and that's a terrible thing
for a president of the united states to
be saying what he is doing
is delegitimizing our democracy
and that is just one more reason why
trump uh must be
in my view defeated and then obviously
we have
different races up and down the ticket
um senators uh
you know state state house
representatives uh
you know a lot of talk about you know a
red wave blue wave
what are you hoping to see from voters
across the country and here in nevada
i'm not much into speculation
i don't know any more than you do or
anybody else does we can speculate all
we want
all that i will say is that this is an
election of enormous consequence
if you believe in honesty
if you believe that a president is not
above the law
if you believe that we need scientific
guidelines to help us deal with this
pandemic and to deal with climate change
then i think the choice is pretty clear
and that is we have to get rid of donald
trump
we got to bring joe biden and kamala
harris
into the white house we need people all
over this country to stand up
and fight for a government that works
for all and not just
the one percent and wealthy campaign
contributors so i would hope that in
nevada which is a
one of a key battleground slate it will
be decided by a small number of votes i
would hope
that large numbers of people come out
today uh come out
saturday sunday monday tuesday whatever
it may be come out
is in as big a numbers as is possible so
that we can
uh defeat uh president trump
senator sanders thank you so much i
really appreciate it thank you very much
thank you